Nhanh Quai Sê bốc đầu xe trên cút lộ bị công an chữ tập. Ngay Mì sau tháng 1, chẳng kính sức
xiao thông ma đàn của Iban造 vụ việc của nhóm Quai Sê cho công an tình lâm động điều tra giấu hiệu
với giới trực công cộp.
Bông qua, mặc sở hội lan chuyên video vi cạnh thành yên trở bạn bằng xin máy trẻ
bị giấu không lượng mũ mà hìa. Nè tù, bốc đầu, lặng lách trên cút lộ hai người đận
qua sả đả của ai. Chi vết sự việc, công an làm việc của người đam tại video là mính hữu sang,
mì bày tuổi ở sả đảng Hoài 2.
Tù lời hai của tuyên này tình sát chữ tập video kiện xe với nước bảo lòng trên phát thải
mùi táng tuổi công nhiều thêm như khác đi chúng nhóm.
Lực lộ chức năng sắp địch hơn 28 giờ ngày 1 tháng 1, lòng,
tại trẻ xe từ sả lộp ăn để tình phố bảo lộ chơi,
rồi nhập nhóm cùng chiến người khác, sau khi xuống đào vào lộp nhóm Quai Sê dù thêm năm
người khác nhập đoàn. Tổng cộng mì hai người đi trên chính xe máy.
Đến mô dự hôm sau khi đến thị trấn mà đàn của ý từ ở ý của người trong đoàn
lòng bốc đầu xe chạy bằng 1 bộ bánh kéo dài nhiều kilomét được sang quay lại.
Trong xuất hiện chính tuy đào vào lộp xuống đự phần sát đồng này và khi chỗ về,
nhóm này đã đến tục lạng lách, đánh phóng, này tư với mất ăn in chứ tự.
Đến chứ cùng này, lòng và sang đăng lên chẳng khá nhân Quay chiến thích.